Tu mora bem pra cheiro aqui né?
É
Tu vai escorrer ou vou?
Cadê o cabo?
É...
60 watts
O que é? Salvo de leite?
Salvo de leite
.
E qual a água foi?
Sim.
Comprar, com quem ensina no final do limite,
porque ela chega na frente de uma carta para ele.
Mas ele já foi para fazer revisão, tá ligado?
Só que para tirar as fontes de valendo,
para tirar as fontes de valendo,
e a um jeito que eu tinha feito.
Enfim, não...
Tipo assim, não tem um ajuste para tirar o preçado,
porque eu não sei.
Mas aí foi ele também me dar isso aqui, né?
Ela me dá uma vez que você fez,
foi bem alguma difícil.
Estou esquecendo, né?
Hum?
Estou esquecendo agora.
O que você quer ter ligado?
Sim, aí foi o Vasco do Fumato, né?
o grande
E... você tá bem?
Tá triste.
Vai se molhar não?